[Music]
fear fear is something that everyone
experiences fear is a feeling that we
all know for me a fear that shaped my
life was we count a time when you faced
a fear a challenge or failure how did it
define you or how did you overcome it
hello got it on sale
very scary I'm sorry I was the
neighborhood I texted you like 10 times
I told you to my phone's off if I miss
this deadline I don't get into Columbia
well then you'll be here with me for the
next four years consider me your safety
school close by good parties oh really
do you also offer creative writing
program oh I'm super creative look I got
you a care package pretty little bit of
Red Bull thank you you're welcome
you are so busted
so so much I've got it mom this is not
what it looks like it no I know what it
is I heard the entire thing do people
not whisper anymore hey I brought
Pringles and Red Bull you better be
quiet cuz my mom will hear us Tyler go
home okay uh just to clarify do you mean
back out the window or out the front
okay I'll use the window
sorry sir Oh see you tomorrow oh I'm
good
go to bed mom I can explain he just
discussed this in the morning
Sam is gonna love this you go to bed too
what if I do I don't need a wingman
[Music]
on you need to stop electrocuting
yourself and eat your breakfast mom this
is due tomorrow and it's worth fifty
percent on my grave about you eat 50
percent of your eggs
son eat seriously sorry
getting close coming morning miss Quinn
good morning Sam hey Cathy thank you so
much for taking Sam we'll be back in
three days we owe you you definitely do
Sonny
grab your backpack honking don't let
just on your bus last night good thing
I'm here now cakes any other dudes
trying to climb through your window
Sonny I'm gonna kill you kill him in the
car okay go go go go Halloween with
pumpkins and mice Halloween hey Cathy
hey kids mr. Chu wow you practically got
a theme park here check this out
oh my that's like I'm gonna have these
puppies up and running in no time you
know for the kids okay hey
ye doesn't actually other things doesn't
know he that's not right everybody let's
make this quick okay guys you can each
pick out a pumpkin to carve if you want
to but meet me back at the register in
five minutes all right okay all right
right here
really yes here everywhere it's all
marquees anything you want to say to me
mom mom I was working all night I swear
I swear Tyler just snuck over and I've
just been so stuck on this essay you're
a great writer Sarah you always have
been when you have to sum up your whole
life in one essay it all just sounds so
unimpressive honey I think you're very
impressive and very capable you doing
thank you
I do just why I need you to watch Sonny
and Sam this week while I'm working
doubles no my name's due Friday
Sonny's bigger than me he doesn't need a
babysitter have you seen what he blows
up when he's supervised I know you're
focused on getting out of here but I
don't cover these shifts at work I could
lose my job I need to know I can count
on you
okay fine really yes really well you
have earned yourself some corn cushions
little lady really mom
they are looking real nice today Kathy
thank you so blue is very in not this
year I see you got the memo I guess
we're in the know okay hey you know the
adult diaper is actually two-for-one if
you want to grab another pack
I just need one today I don't need them
they're for the nursing home right work
of course I don't
I know judgment I use the toilet all
right well uh hopefully y'all uh see you
around soon yeah yeah thanks for
checking me out
ringing up my purchases you know yes oh
yeah just get my diapers and go yeah
happy Halloween
[Music]
dude science fair sometimes I can just
get my Tesla tower to work easily with
he's so cool
what do you mean already cool we are
treasure hunters people respect us
around here a junk bros spitwads
what are you nine would you say Sam what
are you doing I got this
you know we work in a teepee principal
Harrison's house tomorrow night now I
think I'm just gonna spend the whole
night chasing you guys around hey boys
move it or you're tardy of course miss
huger I was just stalling to my good
friends Sam and Sonny ID plug for
homework and all things learning get to
class yeah what a jerk
I'd like to check this book out please
and you are Tyler Mitchell Tyler oh yeah
you have four books you haven't returned
since sophomore year and your account is
frozen damn and it's gonna cost you 40
bucks unfreeze it I just spent it on
tickets for us to see DJ Biscay at the
den tonight you have to come you can't
say no my way of saying sorry for
getting you busted last night I I can't
my mom is making me watch my stupid
brother all week and his friend and I
don't wait for colleagues to start
having fun show starts at 8:00 your
babysitter
[Music]
Sam what do you think nice looks just
like you
yellow yeah yeah you're speaking to a
jump further yes ma'am this afternoon
let me check on my associate hang up on
her right now this we're too busy stop
we're doing this right with the same I
have my test the terror project I have
algebra no way Sam you are in luck
yeah we could squeeze you in 24s Lee
Lane
no no problem no problem okay if you're
not man junk is our middle name Jonathan
do you even hear yourself sometimes get
your shoes on it's time to get rich I
already have my shoes on
[Music]
stern don't like Halloween around here
[Music]
I don't think this place is giving out
candy
[Music]
[Music]
haunted Halloween who would lock a book
did you miss me
awesome you just ate half the fin it
would not do that if I were you so thank
you what can I do
[Music]
maybe they just want us to stay and play
[Music]